en tout les conflits les parties en
présence surtout les dominantes faut
tout pour brouiller l'information bien
évidemment donc là nous avons un état
occupant qui bombarde sont occupés
si j'ose dire ce qui est quand même
comment dirais-je la façon faire des
puissances plus totalitaire que
démocratique disons c'est c'est pas du
tout une coïncidence que de ceux de voir
que le seul point
d'où les journalistes pouvaient avoir
une vue d'ensemble
parce que élevé en hauteur de la
situation sur ce petit territoire où
vivent deux millions de personnes le
seul but a été fracassée exprès par
l'occupant qui d'ailleurs s'en félicite
et c'est toujours la même chose on nous
dit ah oui mais il y avait des espions
du hamas d'accord personne ne trouvera
jamais rien ce sera un prouvable et on
laisse la bonne foi à celui qui bombarde
ça fait des années maintenant que nos
confrères palestiniens sont soumis à des
ddd tactique de d'éviction d'empêchement
d'internement administratif de deux
agressions de blessures certains ont été
tuées et je pense que la communauté
internationale en ce qui concerne les
journalistes comme les autres citoyens
d'ailleurs de ces territoires occupés un
jeu je ne l'aimais pas à part la
communauté internationale ne remplit pas
son rôle
elles devraient s'insurger on n'a pas le
droit de traiter comme cela des civils
des journalistes et des simples citoyens